um the dried Leaf is put into the top
here
like that switch it on and when it
comes to temperature they're nice simply
and ready to inhale from here for over
three decades Chris Cowan took cannabis
illegally to manage his depression and
PTSD I mean really it's potluck with the
type of cannabis that you get when
you're buying illicit cannabis
um
you don't know the quality or the
strength of it so there would be times
where I would take the illicit cannabis
and it would actually exacerbate my
symptoms Chris is now one of the 32 000
people in the UK who take medical
cannabis
for prescription patients have to
receive a medical diagnosis and show
evidence that they've tried other
treatments the difference is is huge
it's still the same plant but it's very
very different to the illicit cannabis
that you get the first thing that I
noticed is that it alleviate my symptoms
right away it doesn't get me high it
doesn't intoxicate me in fact it does
the opposite research commissioned by
Sapphire medical clinics who specialize
in cannabis treatments suggest a quarter
of the public are unaware that medical
cannabis can be prescribed a 1.8 million
people are treating themselves for a
medically diagnosed condition with
cannabis on the illicit Market I think
that's just the figure itself is
something that took us by surprise when
we saw it
GPS can't prescribe medical cannabis
they need to make a referral but some
are unconvinced that it can treat such
wide-ranging conditions it appears to
work for those with intractable epilepsy
and it also appears to work for certain
conditions in multiple multiple
sclerosis but cannabis is now being
proposed for a whole host of other
conditions from Pain to anxiety to
depression so the main problem is that
we need to get a research base while
medical cannabis may continue to be
controversial for patients like Chris
it's life-changing
Alice Porter Sky News